[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
petite j'ai trouvé dans le 2e
arrondissement de paris s'étaient mis
d'accord
mercy qu'est ce qui alors qu'il se
trouve à faire mais parce que c'est son
retour hier soir il devait être là et
forcément
de fil en aiguille de retard 1 forcément
j'ai attendu toute la nuit dernière en
fait est là il est frais il est
disponible
voilà vous pouvez lui écrire bien
entendu il répondra à tous votre
courrier à tout le monde en fait que
cette année serait le pion ah oui le
pire est celui qui va tout voir qui
c'est vrai qu'il a un look de pions on
dirait le surveillant ouais c'est vrai
un petit peu serait que je serai celui
qui voit tout entend tout et surtout qui
balance tout aux téléspectateurs ah oui
voilà je vous aurais pas pu faire sa
chronique celui qui voit tout je vais
donner des notes et distribue des
appréciations et série serait qu'on
attaque ce soir notre quatrième saison
ensemble dont et mp3 quatrième saison
qu'on travaille ensemble ces 4 années
contre saison pour prouver en ce sens ça
me fait plaisir mais aussi retentissant
fut vous avez vu tout s'efface vite st
croix et donc elle le concours comme ses
alliages alors donc forcément je vous
attribue un surnom très affectueux bien
sûr le tarn à bas il faut que vous
connaissez pas ce que vous bâches et
souvent tous les chroniqueurs et beyer
pour la mémoire
jean claude van damme nous a tous venger
les amis il a mis devant cyril hanouna
dont un légendaire oui j'en prendrai mes
distribuer des coups de pied dans la
gueule et les vend tout de suite c'est
jean claude van damme
où il fait chaud pour genève machault
ses émotions je fasse un bisou non c'est
et pour ce magnifique devant jean-claude
mérites d'un autre maximale de 10 sur 10
évidemment rien
i'm amiens vendons pas exactement
alors tout le monde a remarqué que damas
avait très chaud ya way très chaud ce
qui revenait du soda ou coin c'est fou
on est là et on a la photo avec nous et
tout le monde se demander pour qui est
arrivé et peser 75 kg il est reparti 52
à la maison alors on se demande pourquoi
ils avaient si chaud comme ça et bien
j'ai la réponse en fait il était tout
émoustillé jean-claude on fait juste
avant d'entrer en plateau que quelqu'un
ait envoyé une photo sur son téléphone
une photo coquine et sur cette photo
c'était quelqu'un vous ne sait très bien
c'était vous cyril hanouna regarde
cette aide et je me suis mis au golf a
besoin d'un vrai en tout cas ça fait ça
fait plaisir fiso qui n'est quà jaloux
alors isabelle morini bosc a dépassé les
1000 émission était pmp milan oui avec
la force et qu'elle est capable de
raconter mille fois la même anecdote
pense k way que vous l'écoutez pas si
vous l'écoutez pas mais il avait arrêté
très bien comme je t'aime j'écoute tout
ce que tu dis non de la preuve vous
l'écoutez pas
hier c'était la première de la saison
donc forcément mieux demander où elle
avait passé les vacances mais et comme
elle sait vous l'écoutez plus il répond
toujours la même chose mais ce qu'il
faut c'est que personne ne relève que
depuis six ans à chaque entrée non on se
tape les mêmes réponses à son honneur à
quatre les émissions
les vacances ont regardé s'exprime c'est
quand elles étaient comestibles
[Musique]
ce
même pas d'où vient le nom de la plage
où je me suis baigné à l'exercice très
jolie plage d'autres savoirs tout en
herbe près d'evian ça s'appelle amphion
l'ancien magnifique plage il ya des
études
les vacances en haute savoie taille
vient tout simplement tout simplement
avec ma petite famille les écureuils les
signes je me suis
comme avec jallet fait cet été et vous
savez comment s'appelle la plage où je
vais ça s'appelle lampions
[Rires]
[Musique]
ok ça fait de cet été alors oui la plage
dansions pas des liens yapaka que peut
bien
[Applaudissements]
mais ce que je vois c'est que ceux qui
sont là avec elle de migrants ou les
coupes pas du tout cas offert pour une
anecdote qui lui dit c'est fou comme
c'est vrai l'année prochaine au même
endroit ça rassure les personnes âgées
sa dette ou non ça me choque les
personnes
moi je vais toujours au même endroit
aussi vous allez vous à evian confiant
[Rires]
alors isabelle par cette régularité
évidemment je vous mets les
encouragements en espérant que vous
raconter la même histoire pour la saison
11 des vidéos et des encouragements
alors comme je suis le plan ne touche
pas à mon poste j'ai accès à tous les
documents depuis la naissance de
l'émission alors des fois quand je vais
pas bien je me fais les best-of entier
de rachid arhab dompter pouvez
maintenant ça dure 30 secondes on en
parle très vite dans sa voix il est
temps d'ouvrir les babas shibata
alors à voir s'intéresser aux premières
des saisons tpm paix voilà chaque année
les gens se demandent comment vous allez
ouvrir l'année syrie parce que vous
orienter tout à l'heure des heures sur
hyères
depuis quelques temps on a droit à des
intros grandiose mais lors de la
première le 1er avril 2010 sur france 4
c'était pas la même limonade alors cyril
pour la progression des ouvertures
démission je vous décerne les
félicitations monde est parti de très
très loin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes 18 ans rentrait c'était ambiance
mission impossible mais en 2010 c'était
plutôt ambiance les loups la cuisse
madame mademoiselle monsieur bon choix
voici les principaux titres de
l'actualité
d'abord biocoop et si tu fais des
joncaux s est pas de 20 heures mais non
c'est pas du tout 20h lasseter pas vos
posts france 4 c'est vrai d'une comédie
musicale de broadway
m
2010 c'est fou parce que vous parlez
comme juré le père et moi c'est
l'ambiance comme valérie benaïm dans ces
clubs là qu'une chose est sûre on peut
rire de la télévision et on va en rire
ce soir on en a marre des émissions
médias sérieuse n'est ce pas le public
[Applaudissements]
mais n'est ce pas le public franchement
je n'avais pas vu ça j'ai adoré j'ai
adoré vincent s'est retiré en dire et le
redire et le lac de passe partout
exactement
vous allez récupérer la mise oui alors
j'enchaîne bon pour les premiers ne
touche pas à mon poste on reçoit
généralement les plus grandes stars
internationales comme hier jean claude
van damme kenji matt pokora et le 2
septembre 2013 on recevait un autre
immense show man patrick poivre d'arvor
regardez cette photo je trouve
magnifique pour ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas c'est l'ancien
présentateur du jt de tf1 et grâce à
patrick sabatier n'en est rien on avait
appris un truc de fou sur pda rappelez
vous on s'est toujours pas remis de ces
images peuvent choquer la sensibilité
des plus jeunes
patrick poivre d'arvor vous mangez une
madeleine tous les matins wii continue
rappelez vous le 12 septembre 2013 feda
était tombé sur gérard louvin qui
voulait absolument me faire plaisir et
il voulait faire un tu allumes occupé
dès lors que vous l'aimez rien demandé
zack est magnifique en deux ans et si
gérard louvin est devenu ceinture noire
2 tu l'as vu mon cul regardez c'était
exceptionnel vous allez voir ça montrer
dans toutes les écoles
j'avais une question à lui poser depuis
que tu as arrêté le rugby est ce que tu
la revue est-ce que j'ai revu la porte
qu'est-ce que tout la revue lui le rugby
ou toi je commence très mal l'année
[Applaudissements]
non mais vraiment votre question qu'est
ce qui se passe si bien vu s'il l'avait
il l'a pas vu alors tu vas pas vu et
j'ai pas vu qui mon cul
alors pour souhaiter la cité jardin 10
sur 10 toutes les personnes sa mort de
rire tout sauf une évidemment regardé
mon cul
d'autres
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]